here's the thing
when thin people come to talk to fat people about the issues with obesity
they are almost never
ever saying something that we don't already know
right because growing up fat means that you are so cognizant of your health
and of the issues of obesity
and you know what's good
I probably have more understanding of nutrition than the average thin person
because of the amount of nutritionists and dietitians and like
personal trainers that I have personally seen
I stopped dieting in the last six years
and this is the first time in my life that I have been a like
consistent maintain weight
up until six years ago
I was consistently my entire life gaining weight
because I would always gain weight
gain weight gain weight
lose weight gain weight
lose weight but that
that that weight that I
I kind of you know
after I lost and I gained I
I was always more than what I had started off with right (typical of yo yo dieting)
so I had a really
really bad relationship with food
and it wasn't until I started to decided I wasn't gonna die anymore
and I was gonna eat intuitively
and heal my own feelings and relationship with food
that is like what the best that I could have done for *my* health right
and people love to come on to my page
and act as if I do not know what health issues are associated with being fat
there are fat people that work out
that eat healthy that
you know go to the gym
that that
that skip eight hours of sleep at night like
you know what I mean
there are fat people that I believe are healthy
I'm very mentally ill
don't really go to the gym
have a really bad sleep schedule
have like
violent ADHD that impacts every single aspect of my life
like my
most of my health
my the worst part of my health isn't even my fatness
it is my ADHD right
because it impacts every aspect of my life
so when you come into a fat person's comments like
I mean my doctor like
we are locked in
we I have regular checkups
I have regular blood work done
I like
I take my medication
I me and my doctor
we talk about my shit
you know what I mean
ah you don't need to know the details of my personal health
and when you come onto a fat person's page and say
did you know that's actually bad to be obese
babe like
we are very well aware of our health right
and then people who may not have the
privilege to go to doctors and have medications in the way that I do
what how are you benefiting them
you are not giving fat people any new information
when you’re like
obesity is actually bad
babes like
oh my god
especially when you're like
comments are unwarranted and unwanted
if that person is like hi
I'm struggling with obesity
and I would like
you know to deal with my health issues
I you know do you have any information
can you help me
whatever you do that
you guys have that conversation
but if you're randomly giving *unsolicited unwanted advice* to fat people
that's where the fatphobia comes in
because why is this random person's body any of your business
it's not it's not hope that help
moral of the story is don't give people unsolicited health advice
that's that's
that's the issue